let's go to the 202 area code next
caller from 202 who's this hey Dave how
you doing this is a Nabeel a second time
calling I'm actually disappointed that
you just called on me because I could
have listened to these calls coming in
all day this is unbelievably
entertaining but yeah but my question is
about Sarah Palin now feels like we are
in the craziest time right now with
Trump as president so easy to forget
that less than 10 years ago we were one
really old man's heartbeat away from
having Sarah Palin be the president if
only she had gotten a few more million
votes I mean it really wasn't that far
away from from coming about yeah Trump
seems uniquely bad but I was wondering
if you had the chance in 2020 if you
only had two choices between Sarah Palin
and between Donald Trump who would you
choose you know this is really tough
because on the one hand Sarah Palin as
as horrible as she is if if we imagine
Trump getting to do everything he wants
to do and Sarah Palin getting to do
everything she wants to do Sarah Palin
would probably be worse because she's
way more of sort of like a committed
ideological right winger at the same
time Donald Trump because of his sort of
outlandish scandal-ridden nature he'd
probably be less effective at effect
it's sort of like the pence versus Trump
thing but on a greater scale because
Palin is arguably even more incompetent
than Mike Pence so I honestly I might
stick with Trump over Sarah Palin aren't
there a few things that Palin did that
liberals can get behind like could she
socialize the oil in well maybe some
yeah smaller issues people talk about
how Alaska has basically socialized oil
drilling because every resident gets
money but they're doing they're
basically socializing the raping and
pillaging of our natural resources so
it's like there's some left-wing element
of it and a lot of right-wing but you
know what I think if I had to pick I'd
say if Palin replaced Trump she would
she would do more damage and she'd be
more likely to resign I think and it is
that a governor if she did resign she
quit as governor yeah that that's true
she would definitely be I think more
beholden to the GOP and a lot of their
policies but but yeah there's the whole
element of incompetence I mean I don't
even think she would be able to run some
of the businesses that Trump ran he ran
them terribly yeah so III don't I think
she is just so tremendously incompetent
he you know at least when he is
attacking the press he you know at least
knows the newspapers he's attacking if
she famously couldn't even name any well
she reads all of them come on
well of course before all of them yeah
of course my goodness if Yuri watch that
Katie Couric interview just now I mean
you actually will think from in trouble
looks way better it really it yeah its
cringe-worthy alright I appreciate the
call the Beagle did you say your name
was the Beagle what was that it Mara no
Nabeel and own Nabil I'm I might
actually I think you just gave me a new
nickname thank you
the Beagle thank you so much for the
call appreciate that